(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring, what
happened over break, man?
- Hey Rhett, what happened over break?
- I don't know, we hadn't talked about it
because we want to talk about
it on Ear Biscuits, man.
- Imma tell you what
happened over my break.
- This is my 2019 voice, man.
- Yeah, we--
- 2019, I'm regressing (chuckles).
- Post-break.
It's syrupy and Southern-er than normal.
Yeah man, 'cause we did that
thing where we been back,
we been doing a little work.
We been doing some stuff
but we been holding back our
full reports.
- It's like when you held it
in in Camp Caraway for a week.
- Right.
Or everyday at school.
I mean--
- You never took a dump at school?
- I can probably with
98% confidence say never.
But for all of--
- Wow, what?
- For all of my grade school,
middle school and high school.
Never once did a number two at school.
- Now, let me just interject
for a second and say,
I did not know this was
what the conversation
was gonna be, I'm sorry I brought it up,
I don't necessarily wanna--
- That's what I call perfect attendance.
- But I will say,
I didn't make a habit of it.
It wasn't like here at work where I'm
kind of just like a clock, you know?
You have your tea.
- Oh yeah, I wait to do it here at work
'cause that gives me
something to do here at work.
'Cause I mean, what else
am I gonna do, work?
- Yeah but, at school,
because the facilities
are usually--
- Semi-public.
- Soiled in some form.
- Well, all the other kids
see your sneakers and--
- Yeah.
- And your pants around your ankles.
- You gotta have your
dookie shoes (chuckles).
You take your dookie shoes--
- Out of your pockets.
- No, in your backpack.
You take your backpack to the stall,
you get your dookie shoes out,
you put them down, nobody knows it's you.
- Well, I gotta tell Lando that.
- Yeah, if you had dookie shoes,
you can crap as much
as you want at school.
- None of my kids.
- Know about the dookie shoes?
- No because that is not a thing, Rhett.
Of course they don't know about it.
- My kids don't either and I
didn't make a practice of it
but I'd say probably
at least a dozen times
over my school career
I ended up having to
drop a load at school.
I mean, I'm a person, man.
I'm just a human, 2019.
- I am a professional
anal retention human.
So, I'm sorry to get
graphic, but by definition,
I'm good at that.
- You are (laughs).
- Thank you, Rhett.
- So, I have a--
- We got a lot to unload on ya (laughs).
- Yeah, you know, we're gonna
move right on from that.
So, I did a little--
- And this is for real, by the way.
The last time we talked about this,
it was before the break
and we were joshing.
- And I specifically,
I did wanna talk to you about your wife
because your wife
indirectly hurt me over the break and--
- I hope emotionally.
- And you know, okay, so--
- (laughs) I have no clue
what you're talking about.
- I don't know exactly
when things happened,
I just know that this podcast will be live
for everyone to listen to.
- After the LTAT.
- After the LTAT, where
we talked about this, so--
- Yeah, so that's all, you mentioned it.
You're talking about that photo.
I saw the photo and I
was like asking about,
what's wrong with your leg?
- I'll give a little more
context for the photo shoot
later when we talk about
our respective trips
but I did have a photo
shoot in Cabo San Lucas
in which I was wearing
a watermelon outfit that
we talked about on LTAT and Link.
(Link sighs)
I was a little self-conscious
about it but Link did
point out, what's that
wrong with your leg?
What is that stripe on your leg?
- I thought it was--
- Okay, so it was this past Saturday, yep.
- I thought, I mean, you
were standing on the beach,
I just thought that your leg hairs
had like formed a rivulet.
- Captured the wind?
- I thought it was like
wetness formed a hair rivulet
on your right shin.
- It was a scar.
- What?
- It was a scab that,
if you had of seen it two
or three days before that,
it would have been black scab
in that, in that formation.
It's your wife's fault.
- From what I saw of it, it
was, the rivulet or scab was,
I mean it was--
- It was a line.
- A good eight inches.
- Yeah, it was a little bit of a s-curve.
You wanna know how it happened (laughs)?
No, I won't tell you (laughs).
You know what, you're not interested.
- What I'm making up in my
mind is probably a lot better.
- So, as you know, we and
some of our close friends
decided to do Secret Santa
and the way that it was
organized by one of our friends
who took the initiative was
there was some website,
it's not secretsanta.com
but it's something like that
and you go and you put everybody
into a hat, essentially,
a digital hat, and then you find out who
you have to be the Secret Santa for.
- I can't remember, I
would like to remember
what it's called but I can't.
If they're a sponsor, I definitely would,
I will say that and I do like it because
when you get your assignment,
then you can click
on the person and then
they have the option to put
something on their wishlist,
something they would like.
- But only one person did that.
Only one person in our group put what they
wanted on their wishlist
and it was the person
that my wife got the gift for.
- No, actually my person
did too and he said,
I just want you to give any,
listed out some charities
and said I'd like for
you to give to the charities
in my name and I'm like,
I ain't doing that.
- I know who that was.
- That's not fun.
- Yeah.
- I did give to charity but I
also gave him something that
was a gift.
- With a receipt.
- I gave him the, no, I
gave him something else.
- So, I drew your wife.
- You got Christy.
- You can say Christy.
- You know, I just call her
your wife, I do Christy.
- Don't you say my wife's name.
- And I was actually pretty excited about
having your wife as a Secret
Santa receiver because--
- But what you didn't know
was she also drew your name.
- No she didn't.
- Oh, she didn't?
- No.
- Oh, I thought she did.
- No, William did.
- Oh, I don't know why I
thought that, nevermind.
- So--
- You drew her name and
that's all that happened.
- I drew her name and
I was excited about it
because, as you know
and I don't if we've really discussed this
but Christy and I have very similar tastes
when it comes to food.
- Literally.
- And like, chances are,
and first of all, I
kind of like everything,
she kind of likes everything but things
very specifically like olives or cheese or
things that taste a little bit weird.
We tend to agree on those things and so--
- Especially the things
that her and I disagree on
and you and I disagree
on, those things together,
you both really like passionately.
- Right and so I thought, I'm gonna go,
this is kind of a fun
exercise, I'm gonna go
and I'm gonna shop for her
as if I'm shopping for myself
because if I get things that I would like,
then that's kind of getting the things
that she would like, right, and so
and this was a day in which I was
doing quite a bit, I'll
tell you some other things
I was doing that day and other gifts I was
getting for people but
it was essentially like,
it was like December
23rd, Jessie's parents had
been in town and then
Jessie's sister and her family
were coming into town and
there was just a couple
of days before Christmas
that we had to kind of
take care of business
and so I kind of went out
on my own and did a bunch
of last minute shopping.
- This is go time.
- For Jessie, for Christy, your wife,
for my kids, oh, one gift
in particular for Shepherd
that I'll talk about later.
- A little something for me, maybe.
- Yeah and, of course, and,
your wife being happy
is your gift, and so I--
(Link laughs)
- You making my wife happy is not my gift.
That's just weird.
- Now, I was talking to my wife, Jessie,
to figure out what to get your--
- Don't you say her name.
- Your wife, Christy and,
no, I was asking her a
question because I was like,
you know the kinds of things that I like,
where should I go to get those things?
Is this like a Whole Foods situation?
She was like, well, there's this place,
I think it's in Pasadena,
they got like kombucha
and fermented things
and I think that she'd be really into it.
It turns out the place
was in Altadena, I think,
I can't remember exactly where it was,
north of Pasadena and
so I go and I see the--
- Again, if they were
a sponsor, you'd know.
- Yeah and I see the place,
I'm gonna talk a little
crap about the place
so I don't wanna say the
name of the place but
I see the place and
it's in one of those situations where
it's kind of like in
a little downtown area
but then there was a Rite-Aid catty corner
across the street, across the corner
with a parking lot but
it said, for Rite-Aid
customers only and there was a guy sitting
next to his car in a lawn chair
and it seemed like he
was like the guy that
Rite-Aid pays to make sure nobody violates
the parking situation.
I don't know why else he would be there,
it was a little strange.
- Okay.
- And, I don't know if
he's like a shop owner
of one of the other places, whatever,
he had like a bowl of
food that he was eating
on the back of the car that he was sitting
next to as well.
- So he was bound to that location?
- Yeah and so, I was like,
well, I'm gonna pull the old,
you know, the old--
- I'm gonna go to Rite-Aid
but, winky-winky (laughs).
(Rhett laughs)
- I was trying to come
up with a name for it.
- The Rite-Aid winky winky.
- Yeah, so I went into the
Rite-Aid and went in and--
- Did you talk to the bowl
eater before you went?
- No, no, no, no.
- But you parked there is
what you're telling me?
- I parked at Rite-Aid, I walked in,
I did a loop and I came back out.
- Oh, with nothing.
- Nothing, I was gonna get
something, like ChapStick,
something you could always
use but there was a line.
- We have that, we make that ourselves.
- We make it ourselves, exactly,
why do I need that?
So I come back out and then I
walk through the parking lot and I
walk down to this other place.
Turns out they did not have
any of the stuff that
my wife had basically
indicated they might have.
They had stuff that you could
get fresh made right there
but they didn't have, I
thought they were gonna have
like jars of pickled things
and the stuff that I like
that your wife would like, you know.
I wanted to get her some pickled okra.
I did end up finding pickled
asparagus at Whole Foods later,
bone broth and other things but
I'm a little pissed because
I didn't get anything
and I've driven--
- Ooh, strong language.
- I've driven to Altadena,
of all places and
then I come back--
- You could have just gone to Dena.
- That's right and then I see,
well, you know--
- What's so wrong with Dena
that they had to invent
an alternate?
- (laughs) I cross over the
road and at this point I have
the choice of walking around
the barrier 'cause my car
is right there, like there's
a corner and there's a wall
and my car is parked
right next to the wall.
- You're talking like a cinder block--
- Yeah, a concrete wall.
- Three feet tall?
- Three feet tall.
(Link laughs)
Three feet tall and so
I'm like, I'm a big man,
three feet is not big for me.
- You didn't wanna walk next
to the guy with the bowl.
- No, no, no, I didn't wanna
walk all the way around
the wall and then come all the
way through the parking lot,
had nothing to do with the
guy 'cause at this point
I'm getting my car, it
doesn't matter if he knows
I did the Rite-Aid winky
winky, he doesn't care anymore.
- Does he?
- Is he gonna get my license
plate and send the cops
after me, I don't think so.
- Might not let you leave.
- So I wasn't thinking about him at all,
I was just thinking about efficiency of
getting back into my
car and actually getting
to a store to get your
wife what she wanted
and so I was like, well,
I'm gonna do that thing
where you throw your legs over a fence.
It's been years since I've done this.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
You know what I'm saying?
- Okay.
- And so, I get up there--
- Like a rodeo cowboy trying--
- You throw your legs to the side.
- Trying to get on a bull.
- And I
put my hands on the
wall, throw my legs up--
- Pommel horse.
- And then as I make eye
contact with the ground
on the other side,
I realize, oh, it's
higher on the other side,
this is not an even wall.
- Oh, snap.
- And so, instead of just--
- 30 feet.
- I'm not saying it was,
no, my side was three feet,
the other side was four feet.
It wasn't this huge drop.
- But you had to make an adjustment.
- I had to think.
- Oh.
- And in the process of thinking.
- You forgot about that trailing leg.
- I bent my right leg as opposed
to keeping it flying over
and in the process, I had
jeans on, I had jeans on.
- Oh, god.
- Just to give you an idea.
- [Link] Good God.
- My shin hits the top of the concrete
and just like the corner of the concrete
and rakes my full body
weight, like rakes on it
all the way down my
shin or the eight inches
or whatever it was that it
took and I land and I'm like,
oh no.
- Ooh.
- Oh no.
I may have broken my leg (laughs).
- What?
- The first thing I thought was,
I may have broken my leg, 'cause it was,
you know the front of your shin
is like really, really sharp
and I thought--
- Yours especially.
- I thought I had done something.
Thankfully, I was able to get into my car,
my car was right there.
(Link laughs)
If I had to walk across the parking lot,
I don't know if I would have made it.
- Did you think about
calling for bowl man?
- No, no, I got into my--
- Help me, bowl man.
I think I might have broken my leg.
- I get into my car--
- Trying to obfuscate walking past you.
- I get in my car, shut the
door and I just writhe in pain.
(Link laughs)
I'm like, oh no, (groans), I was like
and it wouldn't stop
hurting and I was like, no,
you have not seriously done
something serious to yourself.
I mean, it was hurting to
press the gas and the brake.
- Did you roll up your pant leg and--
- I couldn't, my pants are too tight.
You know what I'm saying?
And it was like, my jeans are tight
so I'm pulling them up
and they're grabbing onto
the flesh that has been
scarred through my jeans.
- Did the jeans rip?
- The jeans are fine, the jeans are fine.
So anyway--
- And I'd like to think at that point,
before you put it in drive, you look up
and he's standing there,
right outside of your door,
just watching.
- I would have no defenses against him,
I would have let him arrest me.
- He's like, dude, $20, man.
- Citizen's arrest.
- You didn't buy anything at Rite-Aid.
- He would have escorted me into Rite-Aid
and I would have get
some thrifty ice cream.
- I'm going with you
to get some ChapStick.
You can't fake an injury
to get out of this.
- I ended up getting to
Whole Foods and getting
your wife some things and
she seemed to be very happy.
She actually texted me a
picture of some of the stuff
that she was enjoying.
- Okay.
- And I was like, great.
- Pickled asparagus.
- Is it good?
- I did not taste that.
- And, anyway, so,
the couple of days after this,
I noticed my leg has got this massive,
it's scabbed up, like I
wasn't seriously hurt,
it was just a superficial
wound but I got this,
it looked like the Hawaiian Islands.
It was like this archipelago,
you know what I'm saying,
of just scabby tissue that eventually,
by the time I got to Mexico,
it was falling off and
then when I took my picture
it was just sort of a red streak and
it's probably almost gone now
but it's your wife's fault but
I think she was happy.
(Link laughs)
And I'm happy that she
was happy and it's a small
price to pay.
- Oh, man, did I get hurt?
You now what, nope, I didn't.
No injuries for the
Linkster over the holidays,
I was coasting, man, coasting.
I had a wonderful time.
I had a moved-to-tears multiple times time
over the holidays and
I'll get into all that.
- Moved-to-tears?
- Yeah.
- That's quite a teaser.
- But first,
let's get into some ads 'cause
let's be real.
- The name of this
podcast is Ear Biscuits.
As you can see, I'm wearing a shirt that
says Ear Biscuits.
I'm drinking from a mug
that says Ear Biscuits.
Not too long ago,
I would've thought that
this was over-branding
and pretentious and then
I got a little desperate
and at that point, I just
started over-branding myself
and I'm okay with it now and
whether you are or not, I'm not
really concerned about that,
I feel good about myself.
I feel good about myself in
2019 and I really feel great
in this shirt that you can
get at rhettandlink.com,
what is it?
Mythical.store.
(Rhett laughs)
- I think if you go to
rhettandlink.com/store,
it'll redirect.
- It'll still go,
but it's actually, we're not
changing it back in 2019,
that was just a little
Rite-Aid winky winky,
not a sponsor,
mythical.store.
- You went in, you came out.
- Yeah, anyway.
- I like this mug.
- It's good, it's got speckle.
- Get the set of three so you can rep
all of our major properties while you're
drinking your beverages.
- And for those of you with three arms,
you can drink all at the same time.
- I think there was,
you know, the question was,
really, how is this gonna play out,
us being in Los Angeles
for our first Christmases.
We saw each other on Christmas Eve,
we got together, we did
that dirty Santa thing.
- Well, Secret Santa,
dirty Santa is different.
- Yeah, you're right, Secret Santa.
- And wasn't that special?
That was something that was unexpected
to have a bunch of
friends over at my house
and we did something that
has never been done before,
at least in my presence.
- It wasn't planned, it was weird,
you talking about the countdown?
- The counting down to the
coming in of Christmas.
- Yeah.
- To the turn of Christmas,
from Christmas Eve to--
- It was like New Years Eve,
the strike of the New Year
but it was Christmas instead.
- And we had our group of
friends and all their kids,
all together, literally--
- Chanting.
- Playing the guitar, chanting,
what is the song that, I missed that.
- The Shark--
- The Shark Song?
- Oh, gosh, it was something
like, I can't remember it
right now.
- I don't know what it is.
- Do you remember the tune
of the countdown that we did?
♪ Seven minutes ♪
- I don't know about this.
I'm out of the loop, man.
I'm out getting gifts for your wife,
the Shark Song apparently
was something that was big,
I don't know.
- It's a kid's song.
- Anyway, so, we sang
that and I went downstairs
to the garage and the
floor was buckling under
everyone jumping up and down.
I was like, should I stop the celebration?
I mean, if they all fall into my garage,
is that still worth it?
- That was special, man.
- It was fun.
Is it gonna be a tradition,
that was what I was thinking
as it was happening.
I need to get two by
sixes in the floor if so.
- Of course, you know
me, I almost missed it
'cause I was, you know I
was trying to gather up
my children and go home
like an hour before.
- You were trying to get out of there.
- But, I heard all this
chanting and I had gathered
up my keys and the food,
the leftovers that nobody
ate that we brought and I was gathered up
and ready to head out
the door and you know,
get on with the Christmas,
getting ready for Christmas morning
'cause we had plans and
then we're about to go
out the door and I realize,
whoa, this chanting thing is,
like everybody's all in and it's,
they're saying 14 minutes, so.
- At least you knew how long you had.
- Yes and I'm like, well,
I can stay for 14 minutes
and then lo and behold, like
literally every millisecond
of that was part of a
countdown leading up to it
and we stayed for it and that was amazing.
So that was a great start.
Then we go home.
I'm gonna leave Santa
out of this, alright?
- Understood.
- None of what I'm talking
about has anything to do
with what Santa did at my house.
This is, I'm only gonna
talk about the part that
me and Christy did.
- Got it.
The supplemental stuff.
- Yeah, so in addition
to anything Santa did
or might have done or wanted
to do or wished he had done,
Christy and I had our
own plan that the kids
didn't know about that we
needed to put into action
that night.
I'm pretty sure this is Christy's idea
but I was, the moment she said it,
we were out on a date, we're like,
we gotta, we were talking about,
we got to figure out what we're gonna do,
this is our first Christmas
here in LA with the kids
as opposed to going back home.
We got to start developing
some traditions, you know,
like I've been talking about,
and then she pitched this idea
and I immediately knew, as
she started to pitch it,
just jump onboard, don't even analyze it,
you now how I have a tendency to like
tweak and analyze.
- Oh, really, you have
a tendency to analyze?
- Yeah but I can do this
and it will be better
or what if we did, I was
like, I was just, yes man.
It was a brilliant idea.
- You should use that more often.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
- Just with her.
The idea was,
Christmas morning, scavenger hunt.
Kids are gonna come down,
well, we don't have an upstairs,
we do, but it's just me
and Christy's upstairs,
all the house is downstairs
for everybody else, you know,
you gotta use the pecking order here,
so they're all downstairs.
They're gonna flow out into
and go to the Christmas tree where
all the presents are
and then they're gonna find out,
oh, uh-uh, ain't no
presents under the tree.
The tree was like full
of presents under there,
so we moved all of them and
hid them all around the
house, outside of the house,
in the washing machine,
in the grill, in the car
and then we had one bear,
unwrapped, with a card on it
and it had the first clue
and boy, we were so excited about it.
(Rhett laughs)
You know and then you'd
open that up and it was
a letter and it was--
- From the bear?
- No.
A letter from us and it was,
it even rhymed, it was
a poem that I wrote.
Yeah, man and at the end
it had the first clue
to find the presents
and we were so excited.
Of course, ended up staying
up to like 2:00 a.m.,
that's not something that
I do, I'm no elf (laughs),
but I did it, 'cause we were excited.
So then we get down there and we're like,
Lando came up to our bedroom
first before he went in there
and he got, he woke Lily
up, I mean, she's 15,
turns out, by the time you turn 15,
if you don't have to go to school,
you could literally sleep.
- Into the afternoon.
- For days.
- Yeah, of course.
- I don't know, if we don't wake her up,
I just don't when she
would ever wake up and
Lincoln knew that he was
getting an electric guitar,
so he wasn't too motivated
to get out of bed either.
So we get them out of
bed and we're like, okay,
go in there and get the presents
and then we're like watching
and they go in there
and they're, you know,
it's, ah, joke's on you,
the presents aren't here and they're like,
kind of groggy and they're like, well,
and then Lando's the most
excited, I mean, he's eight
and he's like opening the
card and they're reading
the poem and at this point,
I expect celebration,
scavenger hunt!
- You know, you could have
consulted me (laughs).
- What seems obvious to
me now is that it's like,
Christmas morning, you run downstairs
and all the presents are
gone and there's nothing
but a letter and we
have to answer a riddle.
(Rhett laughs)
So they were a little underwhelmed.
- Yeah, maybe you should
have been a little more,
maybe you should have
analyzed it a little bit more.
- Oh, I thought you
said maybe I should have
been a little more animated.
- No, no, no.
- I'm like, dude, I was animated.
I was like, scavenger hunt, guys!
Yeah!
- So what ended up happening?
- Well, they had to solve the
riddles to get their presents.
So then, so by the time they
found the third present,
they were waking up more,
it was kind of like,
there's like a delayed
reaction of the scavenger hunt.
You get to your third
clue, it's like an infusion
of caffeine.
They kind of got onboard.
- In my experience, scavenger hunts,
really hot out of the gate,
you know what I'm saying
and only go downhill from there.
- I think that they
saw the look on my face
of disappointment and
still hope and expectation
that this like, let's
just do this for Dad.
- Yeah, wow, okay, so,
is this a tradition now?
- But they got into it and
when they found the presents,
they were still wrapped, by the way.
- Well yeah, of course.
- So then they would, they
would take the presents
and they would put them
in a pile or separate them
and then they would--
- After awhile, at what
point did it become more
of an Easter egg hunt?
Do you have to follow the clues, 'cause--
- You gotta follow the clues.
- But you know, oh, maybe
one's in the washing machine.
- I think there were 10,
there were 10 locations, okay?
- Total?
- Yeah, total.
- They worked as a team to
get everyone's presents.
- They worked as a team,
so each location would
have multiple presents,
like one for each kid
kind of a thing and
so they came around to it
and then I really think
it's about, now next year,
yes, it is a tradition,
we are gonna do it and
they're gonna be emotionally
prepared.
- But you're gonna hire a
scavenger hunt company to do it.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
Right?
You're not gonna do it yourself.
- What do you mean?
You don't think?
My clues were lit, like a tree, man.
So we're gonna do that.
So then we were back to square one,
they were opening the presents and then
we were proceeding from
there and it was good to go.
- And we actually both got
our kids an electric guitar.
You got Lincoln one, I got Locke one.
Now I went with Locke
so he could pick it out.
- Yeah.
- Oh, Lincoln had already seen his guitar?
- We went, we picked out
the guitar that he wanted.
He wanted a Telecaster form,
of course I'm not gonna get
him an actual Telecaster,
I got him the preliminary
version of the Telecaster,
the Squier Telecaster.
He got to prove himself before
he moves to the big leagues.
- When you were at the guitar shop,
did you see the Jaguar?
The Fender Jaguar, the same thing?
It's like a Squier version?
- The cave had an apron over it, what?
No.
- That's what we ended up getting.
- What?
- Jaguar, Jaguar.
- Is it made by Fender?
- It is a shape that
you would recognize that
is a little different.
- Like a Jazzmaster?
- No, it's just a different shape.
It's got a few more bells and whistles,
not that it necessarily does anything.
It's all the same price.
They're all in that Squier range
but I knew that you had
gotten the Telecaster.
- I'm thinking about
turning my garage into a,
like a garage band site.
- Yeah, like that, that's
what it looks like.
- Yeah, that's a Jazzmaster body.
- Okay, same thing then
but it says Jaguar in it.
- Cool colors.
- We almost got that one but
that one was more expensive.
- I'm sure people know more than me
and I'm probably wrong.
- So we got like a candy apple red one.
You got him an amp?
- I'm thinking about
turning the garage into a,
yeah, got an amp.
- Which amp did you get?
- A Fender.
- The one that has the
stuff built into it,
like the sounds?
- Yeah, yeah, I think.
- Probably got the same amp.
- It was like 100 bucks.
- Okay, I got a better amp.
- Oh, you did?
(Rhett laughs)
Oh, I see how it is.
- It wasn't that much more expensive
but it wasn't 100 bucks.
- Maybe I got the same amp
but I just got a better deal?
- Okay, alright.
Yeah but you're gonna turn your--
- Did you hide it?
- Uh, no.
- Well, there you go.
- I didn't hide it.
But the most exciting gift that I got
was for Shepherd though because Shepherd,
as you may recall, on the--
- Good Mythical More.
- In the episode, went over
the fill-in-the-blank on
Christmas lists but then
in Good Mythical More
they went over their lists.
- And I watched that
back, we watched that back
as a family 'cause I was like,
Shepherd, have you watched the show that
you were on yet and he was like, no.
This is like a week after it had been out
and so, we sat down,
Jessie and Shepherd and I,
watched Shepherd on the show and
then we watched Good Mythical More and
that was when I realized
that, oh, you know,
when he went through his Christmas list,
that was actually a real thing,
it wasn't just for entertainment purposes.
That's the way I think about the show,
it's like we have these conversations.
- Right.
They're not like us.
- There's no real world
application for this.
(Link laughs)
We said we're gonna do this but we're not.
- Right.
You don't really like wood.
- Exactly, so.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
So I--
- Hold on.
Okay, just tell me, 'cause
I remember what he--
- He said he wanted a snake.
You want a reptile or something
from the reptile family?
How 'bout a snake?
- Yeah, I want a snake.
- Okay, your mom will love that.
- I remember, did you get him a snake?
- I got him a snake.
Well, 'cause Jessie was like,
she saw him mention snakes, she was like,
oh, you still want a snake?
He'd been talking to her
about how he wants a snake
and so, I don't--
- 'Cause I kind of thought Shepherd
was just being Shepherd when
he said he wanted a snake.
- I don't mind snakes
and I thought that this
might be an opportunity
for him to get a little
responsibility or something
to have to take care of this snake.
- Yeah, I'm sure the
snake appreciates that.
Learn responsibility or kill a snake.
- Well, you know, I mean,
you gotta weigh the pros and cons here.
- It's not a mammal.
- I'm gonna step in and take care of this
cold blooded animal as needed.
- You got a snake?
- Yeah, so first of all--
- How do you wrap a snake?
- Well, the first snake (laughs),
we didn't wrap, no, I'm just kidding.
- Oh (laughs).
- No so, you don't wrap
a snake but what I did do
is I went to
the pet store here in Burbank
that we got Craig from, actually.
- Really?
- The one that they tried
to take Craig back to
'cause this place has a bunch of reptiles,
great pet store, Scales 'N' Tails,
I'll shout 'em out.
- Not a sponsor.
- Not a sponsor but--
- Of anything probably.
- It's basically the place
in Burbank to get pets
but definitely get reptiles and
sort of exotic pets
and that kind of thing,
so I go in there and I have
my mind set on a corn snake.
In the little bit of
reading that I have done,
corn snakes are easy, great
for your first snake and
you can get these weird colors and stuff.
We got the, I think they call
it the Okeechobee mutation,
they're like orange and red.
- Okay.
- It's a mutation, not normal.
- You say when you get your first snake
as if you plan on getting more snakes.
- No, I mean, this is the first
and probably the last snake
but I'm saying, I didn't
wanna get something
that you have to think about a whole lot.
- It's not that big around,
it's like as big around
as my thumb, right?
- Yeah but they can go to six feet long.
- For real?
- But more likely four feet long is
what this thing--
- They're fast too, aren't they?
- Yeah and it's a lively snake.
- They can get away in the house.
- They like to be handled and
that kind of thing.
- Or get away.
- What, yeah, I mean
they could get away but
we know the protocol
but I had to come here,
I actually had to come here to,
'cause they just give you the snake
in a little plastic,
like something you'd get
takeout at a restaurant with,
that's what they put the snake in.
I was like, I'm not interested
in eating the snake.
He's like, no, this is how we,
this is how we transport the snakes,
little paper towel and some holes in this
little plastic thing.
- Like a wanton.
- Yeah and--
- Takeout.
- They give you the whole
setup and you got, you know,
your heat lamp and there's
a pad underneath it.
You got to have a hot side and cold side.
There's water, all that.
I came here to do all this
on Christmas Eve.
- Oh, gosh.
- No, two days before Christmas and
so the snake, who Shepherd
ended up naming Moose,
by the way.
(Link laughs)
Moose the snake.
- That's cool.
- Was in our office, sealed up,
he couldn't get out of the terrarium
but the minute, I'm just
gonna talk to you about
the disturbing side of reptile ownership
because this is something
that I had not anticipated
but I kind of understood.
I mean, I know--
- I think I understand.
It's called just having a
snake, that's disturbing enough.
- No, no, no,
it gets dark.
It's gonna get dark.
- Er.
- So, again, I don't mind the snake.
He seems almost kind of cute.
First of all, we don't know
if it's a male or a female.
Apparently, finding out the
sex of the snake involves
a probe of some kind and
you gotta be like an expert.
It's not just like you just
turn it over and look at it
and so, even the guy
was, I don't know if it's
a male or a female and I'm not,
and the implication was,
and I'm not about to find out for you.
So, we just went with
Moose, it could be a male
or a female.
- Right, there are--
- We don't plan on breeding it.
- There are male and female meese.
- And so,
but I'm like, so what do I feed it?
Oh, you feed it pinkies.
- Pinkies.
(Rhett mumbles)
There's four of us, two hands.
- The smallest finger on each of my hands?
- Eight McLaughlin pinkies.
- That's not gonna last long.
He's like, these baby mice.
There's no alternatives?
- Like baby hairless mice?
- So, the dude proceeds to
and listen, if you are
like super animal lover,
you may wanna skip this part because
basically, they have mice,
live mice in the pet store
at different stages and he reaches in,
he reaches in, he's
like, this is what you're
gonna start feeding him
and he just pulls out
this little teeny baby mouse
that has no hair on it,
it looks like, just something
that just popped out of--
- Oh, gosh.
- Like a little preemie looking thing.
- Like, can't even see
and he was like, yeah,
you're take it and you're gonna put it
in the bag with the snake.
Then he says, but you can get frozen.
- Yes, I want frozen.
So, first of all, I wasn't gonna deal with
the live situation, which technically,
a lot of people, including
this guy, said that
if you wanna be safe,
you give them frozen from
the beginning and frozen from then on out
so that they can't get
injured because, you know,
a mouse will bit a snake as
it's going down, you know?
- Oh, gosh, okay, okay.
- But, these people,
just so you understand--
- I wasn't in the market for a snake,
why are you trying to talk me out of it?
- Because I just want you
to understand the reality.
People who have--
- Why?
- And I don't know why I've
never thought about this but
people who have snakes,
he's like, as it gets older,
you're gonna wanna continue to go up.
He's like, there's
pinkies and then there's,
he called them softies
or something or fluffies,
and small mice and then large mice.
Okay and Craig also eats
frozen mice as well.
So we're doing all frozen here but
these are just mice that are just bred
in order to be given to reptiles.
(Link groans)
And--
- This was our happy holiday episode.
Get this over with.
- But the interesting thing is that
on the animal ethics scale,
you've got these more developed mammals.
- Yeah, yeah, like I said earlier,
it's not a mammal.
- More closely related to us,
they actually have another
part of their brain
that gives them the
opportunity to process thoughts
on a different level and to
enjoy bonding and this stuff
and we're feeding it to the
lower life form, the snake,
because this is the way
that the world works.
There are no vegan snakes
and so then I was like,
does this mean that there
are no vegan snake owners
or if a vegan snake owner has a snake,
they're just like, well,
I'm not eating the mice,
he's eating the mice.
I don't understand the ethics of it.
- Let the snake snake.
- I'm not a vegan.
I understand that we're
all part of the food chain.
I understand that this is
what snake ownership involves
but I'm not gonna deal with the live ones,
I'm gonna deal with the
frozen ones and I really don't
wanna know what happens before that.
- You gotta microwave them before you
throw 'em in the cage?
- You can but you shouldn't,
you just set it out and let it thaw.
If you microwave it, it's
uneven and it can get hot
in certain places, it
can injure your snake.
- Okay.
- So what I do is I take the snake,
I put it into, this is what this guy says,
you put it into a little brown
bag with the thawed mouse
once a week, you basically fold it closed,
put it back in it's cage
so he eats in a different environment
so that he does not
get the idea that I eat
in this terrarium 'cause
then you might stick
your hand in there, he thinks it's a mouse
and eats it.
- A pinky, he thinks
your pinky is a pinky.
- Eventually as the snake gets bigger,
you're gonna have to have a feeding,
if you got a huge snake,
like a 20 foot snake,
you got to have a feeding bin, you know?
At that point, you're
giving it a rat to eat.
I saw somebody, I was in line,
a woman comes in, she's like,
I want one of the large rats.
The guy reaches in the
fridge, pulls it out,
was holding, there's a dead rat.
- And that's like a couple
times a year for that
big snake I would think.
- No.
Maybe every 10 to 14 days.
- Ew.
- I don't know but Moose is once a week.
- Man, my Christmas is
over and you ruined it.
(Rhett laughs)
- It's just the reality, man.
♪ It's the circle of life ♪
Where's Elton John when you need him?
- So after everybody got
their presents opened,
everybody's playing their
new guitars and Lando's
loading up his gumball machine.
He asked for a gumball machine.
Your next on the list is another machine,
this is a gumball machine.
- A small one.
- Okay, good, a small one.
We got that.
- Oh, really?
- No mice in there.
- But you can probably
put the little pinky mice
in the little balls, that
would be kind of cool.
We put that in Shepherd's room and that's
where he gets the mice.
- That's where the corn
snake crawls up inside,
put the corn snake in the--
- In the gumball machine.
- That'd be cool.
- That could be weird.
- That's a cool terrarium.
- Yeah.
- We did not get Lando
a claw machine like he
asked for because the
reasons that I told him.
- Yeah, it'd be overkill.
- And then, in the effort
to further traditions,
we're like, LIly's gonna make a meal,
she made this beef stroganoff
meal for our dinner
and we're all sitting down at the table,
like gathered around, eating our meal.
This is the evening, Christmas
evening by this point
and we're sitting down
and we're eating this meal
that my daughter prepared, it's fabulous.
Everybody's happy, has got their stuff and
I just find myself weeping.
(Rhett laughs)
At the table.
I literally found myself
weeping tears of joy
at my table.
- Here's the thing though is that,
20 years from now, you're gonna start,
the estrogen is really
gonna be getting produced.
- [Link] Yeah?
- At that point, you will,
many men find themselves
weeping for no reason at all.
- Nothing to weep.
- You're getting started at 40.
- Yeah.
- You just need to,
you gotta pace yourself
a little bit.
- It kind of caught the fam
off guard a little bit and--
(Rhett laughs)
I think Christy knew what was happening
and maybe she teared up a little bit,
maybe she gave me a pat on the shoulder
but the realization I was having was just
tremendous gratitude for this family.
I mean, you've got these people who are,
they're their own people but we, you know,
we made them in a certain sense (laughs).
- Yeah.
- Well, I think, specifically,
it was the first time in
a long time that we had
our own Christmas thing
and it was that we had
our own thing for the first
time that was distinct
from the rest of our family
and we missed them.
We missed our family not being there but
and I was a little sad
about that and we did
talk to them and do video
chats throughout the day
and stuff like that but I realized that
I actually felt very much,
very fatherly for the first time
and I started thinking about--
- Feeling fatherly.
- Traditions, because when the
rest of your family's there,
when your parents or maybe older siblings
or other extended family is there,
relationships go up and
they go down in time but
when it was just us,
I was the, you know,
I was the only father around.
So, it was a very different
feeling that kind of
stuck up on me, that's
like, we have a thing
and I think that it was something that
my family, that encouraged
us to do our own thing,
I think they knew better than I did
that's it like, yes, you
need to have this sensation
and I realize that I just had not had it
and when I realized that I was having it,
I started to cry and it
was very, I was very happy.
- Does this mean that you're gonna,
like this Christmas now?
You're not gonna be home anymore?
- I don't, yeah, I don't know.
- I mean, as long as Locke
keeps playing basketball,
we have to be here.
So, I don't have a choice
for four years but--
- I mean, at this point,
we haven't talked about that specifically,
so I don't know exactly.
- But it sounds like it was pretty moving.
- It was very moving, so yeah,
that is a big tick in the yes column
of let's do this again, let's
continue to build on this.
- Well, I will say, I teared up
at the Christmas meal but it was because
I nearly burned the house down
and it was just the smoke
coming from the oven.
- What?
- Yeah,
but it was beef.
- I'm sure this was my
wife's fault, so go for it.
- But it wasn't beef stroganoff,
it was Beef Wellington.
- Ah, that's not easy.
- Well so,
Jessie's parents had
been in town, they left,
we had a couple days, we kind of did some
just the us McLaughlin's thing and then
Jessie's sister and her family,
so husband and two boys,
about, you know, high school age boys,
so a little older than Locke,
were gonna come stay but
they flew in on Christmas Day
and so we're like, okay,
well, we're gonna prepare
Christmas dinner so we
can all have it together
when the get there and Jessie and I,
we fancy ourselves as culinarily skilled,
although we're not but
we're adventurous and
we were like, she's like,
well, I'm gonna do these
Cornish hens because we
do Cornish hens every year
as our Christmas dinner
before we go back home
but now we're gonna make
it at Christmas dinner
but I was like, but what if
we tried Beef Wellington?
Ever since I watched that
first season of Hell's Kitchen
and heard Gordon Ramsey talk about it,
I had this idea of how awesome it would be
to make Beef Wellington,
so we made all of them
at the same time.
- That's ambitious.
- (sighs) We ended up, we couldn't put
all of it in the oven at the same time
and we ended up putting the
hens directly on the grate
in the oven and then put
these drip pans underneath it
and then everything was
dripping off of the Cornish hens
and it was smoking up the
house and the fire alarm
kept going off and it was
freezing, as you know,
for LA, it was freezing on Christmas Day,
it was in the 40s, can you believe it,
which is super cold to us at this point,
'cause, you know, we've adjusted,
so I got all of the
windows and doors open.
I did tear up a little bit, but again,
it was because of the smoke in the eyes.
- There were no flames though, just smoke?
- No, no flames and actually--
- Was there yelling?
- The meal, Jessie and
I, yeah, a little bit.
- Christmas Day yelling?
- I mean, it's not--
- hey, that's part of it, man.
- It's not Christmas if you're
not yelling at each other.
- Yeah.
It's part of it.
- And the meal was really good.
It ended up being great,
nothing was burned.
It was just the drippings had
created the smoke situation.
- Okay.
- I don't know if I'm gonna make that,
the smoking up the house, a tradition
but it is the kind of thing that
becomes a tradition.
You know, like you tell
the story of the time
the whole house got smoked up and then
400 years later, there's
a dude with incense,
he's like, we light this incense in honor
of the time Rhett and Jessie McLaughlin
nearly burned their house down,
like that's how traditions start,
it's always something stupid.
- Well, that sounds more
like a religion and--
- Oh, did I tell you, I'm
starting a religion (laughs)?
- Yeah, that's different.
- It's 2019, the year I start a religion.
- So then,
I embarked on my trip to--
- Just really quickly,
because I had everybody,
I had family there for those two different
periods of time and I learned
something about my dog.
I'll show a picture
at the appropriate time
here on the feed but
my dog is unfaithful.
Barbara is unfaithful.
- Well, I knew that.
- You know that Barbara
seeks attention from
whoever is there but when
Jessie's parents were there,
she slept in the bed with Jessie's parents
and of course, Jessie's whole family,
they're all dog people, they don't care,
they love her, they
think she's incredible,
if Barbara tried to sleep with my parents
it would be a little different but
so Barbara is like
sleeping with the enemy,
not the enemy but (laughs).
- Oh, you, oh, you said it.
You said it.
- And sleeping with Jessie's parents
and then sleeping with
Jessie's sister and her husband and
even going to the point of
getting in their suitcase.
I have a picture, I'll show it now.
This is Barbara
in, for those of you who
are watching the podcast.
- [Link] Like trying to--
- I don't know if she's
trying to send the message,
I wanna go home with you, I hate it here
because she seems to love us as well
because what she'll do
is she'll spend all night
down there and then in the morning,
she'll come and start
scratching at our door
and then wants to come in
and just make out with me,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm not making out with you right now.
You've been making out with
other people downstairs.
(Link laughs)
It's not time for that.
- But you did let her in.
- Yeah, I do it, I can't help it.
She also wore a sweater pretty much
the entire holiday season.
- Oh, festive.
- Yeah, it was just, I don't know,
one day she just had a sweater on.
- What does she think about the snake?
- Does not care about Moose at all.
Doesn't bark at him, doesn't look at him,
doesn't sniff him.
Shepherd brought him down Christmas Day,
holding him,
Barbara doesn't care.
We were wondering if
she was gonna freak out
and like try to attack it.
- Well, did Barbara see the snake?
- Yeah, she seemed to but she didn't
seem to care about it.
Maybe she was friends with
a snake in a previous life.
I don't know.
- Now, if she gets in the
aquarium with the snake,
I know that's not what's it
called but whatever, then--
- Terrarium.
- Then you're really being cheated on,
like you should really
take that personally,
if she's curled up with the snake.
- She might try.
- So after Christmas, we went
to Sedona, Arizona because,
again, like I said last Ear Biscuit,
we decided not to do the RV thing,
we wanna get there quick.
The place that I found, it had
a great view out the window
of the red rocks that
are signature for Sedona.
Unfortunately, we
couldn't take Jade because
they wouldn't allow her in this place and
that was my one regret
is that Jade was not with us but
this place, I mean, a lot of
friends had told us about it
and they talked it up and
that's why I wanted to go and
I knew there was a lot
of good day hiking and
I'm still trying to foster
the love for the nature
with my family and taking nature walks,
I don't call them hikes
'cause like we've talked
about before, my kids
have decided they don't
think they like to hike, so you
just call it something else.
- And it works?
- Or just don't tell them you're doing it,
oh, we're walking to
the car but we're gonna
take an alternate route
and then lo and behold,
we're out here in nature
for three hours and
they're loving it.
So that was my vision.
- You can do a scavenger
hunt out there as well,
just so you know.
It should be pretty fun outdoors.
- This is a, you could do
a spiritual scavenger hunt
because this place is like, I mean,
call it new age-y, okay,
in the 70's there was some
psychic woman who went there
and said, oh, this is a
hot bed of spiritual earth
energy activity and there are,
'cause you go in and there's,
it's a two lane road
that kind of goes through
into kind of a valley,
then you're driving past
these red rock formations
on either side of the
road and it's absolutely
breathtakingly beautiful, it's like.
- Is this where Red Rocks, the theater is?
- No.
- Where John Tesh played?
- No, but it is, it is
the same type of rocks,
I do believe.
The iron content, you got
like a rust situation going on
and the erosion exposes these
amazing looking formations.
There's one natural bridge
called Devil's Bridge
that you can hike to.
I ended up not going for weather reasons,
so I'll have to go back but
I mean, it's absolutely beautiful.
So, in the 70's, it was
determined to be this
place where there was a
lot of spiritual energy
going in and coming out of the earth
in places called vortexes.
- Vortexes.
- Which we learned
about vortexes back when
we went to Tonopah, Nevada
as part of Commercial Kings,
we made a tourism ad for
them for that episode and
I'm still reasonably proud of that episode
and I saw the sign for Tonopah
when we were driving.
- And Tonopah has a vortex.
- That's what they say, right?
We ended up, so there's a lot of,
it's very hippy, spiritual,
so you got the beautiful
scenery, lots of people hiking,
lots of shops with lots of crystals
where each crystal does something special.
- Other than just sit there and be a rock.
- Right.
- And there's four vortexes.
- There's four?
Sedona's got four.
- It's got four and--
- How many Cheesecake
Factory's does it have?
- Zero.
- Wow.
- So, weigh that.
- Okay, alright.
Priorities.
- We signed up for a Jeep tour for one day
but as I was looking for that,
there was also a vortex tour
that I thought about taking
where the description was
written by the one tour guide
who said, if you have a
party of four or less,
you meet me at this gas
station and you can get
in my car and I will
drive you to the vortexes.
You can experience a male
vortex, a female vortex
and general spiritual goodness.
If you have a party of five or more,
I'll get in the car with you
and we'll do the same.
So, at that point I just,
I didn't pursue that one any further.
- How big around is a vortex?
- Well--
- I'm thinking about
how big of the party is
I'm gonna take.
(Link laughs)
- Right.
- Do we all get in one
at a time or do we all,
does the whole group get
in and can you feel it?
- It's not a hole.
- No, it's like a tornado,
it's like a spiritual tornado.
- It's pretty big.
For one, there's a rock called Bell Rock,
which is pretty freaking big but you can,
if you're physically
capable, you could hike up
to the top of the Bell in an hour, okay,
so that gives you an idea how big it is.
It's shaped kind of like a bell.
We hiked this.
It is a vortex.
The entire formation.
- Is a vortex.
- Okay.
- That's all I can say about it.
- You didn't feel it?
Did you feel it?
- I felt joy being there.
I felt exhilaration and
a little fear climbing up
because Lando kept wanting to climb up
and I kept saying,
climbing up's easy buddy,
it's the climbing down
that's difficult.
- But in a vortex you don't
have to worry about gravity.
- That's what he said.
- Oh.
- And I was like, nope, I'm not buying it,
so every so often I would make him
crawl ahead and then prove to me that
he could crawl back down
and the rest of the family
had long since bailed on this entire.
- They didn't go up into the vortex?
- We went, they went halfway up the Bell
and then we went another
third of the way up,
beautiful place, just can't,
I have nothing more to say about a vortex.
I don't know, I just
didn't experience anything,
I should have signed up for the tour.
- You weren't open.
- I should have got--
- You were closed.
- We should have got the woman in our car.
- You have to open your
heart in the same way
that the vortex is open and
then you'd understand it.
- We did have a couple
of magical experiences.
The first one, we get there that night,
we're eating pizza and then
the employees at the place say,
oh look, it's, there's a snow flurry,
it's the first of the season.
- Was it going in a vortex pattern.
- It was not.
- That would have been important for me.
- They went outside and it was like wow,
they actually don't get
a lot of snow there,
'cause I was reading online and it's like
if you're hiking, you might
be lucky and there might be
a dusting of snow on the red
rocks, which can be beautiful.
Turns out, Lando had never
seen, I didn't realize this,
he had never seen falling,
natural falling snow.
- Hmm.
- You know?
'Cause we'd been out here since he was,
before he was two years old and
he hasn't seen snowfall except for manmade
at a ski resort last year at this time.
That was special but then the next day I
take him out hiking or on
a nature walk, wink, wink,
and it starts snowing and
we went on a hike, dude,
in the snow and it was awesome.
I mean, it was like--
- This is where I saw
some of the Instagram's
from your family, right?
- Yeah, it's like nothing,
I mean, it's like,
you can go your whole
life and not hike in snow
falling on the red rocks,
especially in Sedona,
from what I've heard.
It was pretty special.
We had a blast.
- Did you cry then?
- I had a little tear action happening.
- And there was no beef
stroganoff involved?
- No, not at all.
- 'Cause you need to
isolate what the trigger is.
- Yeah, trying to correlate what it is.
- If it's not beef stroganoff,
it may be just being with your family
and having good times.
- Well, how sad is that?
(Rhett laughs)
It's gotta be something else.
The next day, we took a
Jeep tour which turned out
to be actually kind of lame
but you can rent Jeeps there
and do--
- Extreme off-roading?
- Aggressive off-roading,
which, in a lot of
places you can't do that,
so that's another cool thing about that
if you wanna go to Sedona, not a sponsor.
- Sedona, not a sponsor.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
An entire town, not a sponsor.
- The next to last day we're there,
it starts snowing.
We go out for brunch and
this is an unexpected snow
and it's dumping snow.
By the time we come out
an hour and a half later,
we had driven four minutes to eat brunch.
We come out, we get back in the car,
it's like seven inches of snow.
It's crazy.
It was amazing.
It took us over two hours to drive
the four minute drive
back to our condo because
the place just wasn't ready for it.
It shut down.
We drove for an hour,
we didn't move hardly
and I was like, alright guys,
get out and just walk home
and they had a blast
just kind of walking home
in the snow blast and
I had some alone time
with my vortex.
That sounded weird.
I was just in the car listening to--
- Yeah, understood.
- But I listened to like--
- Vortex music.
- Spa music, it was really--
- You got get everything in line.
- It was really,
and then, so we get back home,
have some coffee, I finally get there
and the sun's going down and I'm like,
we can hike back up this
trail from our condo
and Lando and I went out
there and that's the picture
that I showed in LTAT that
I got him to take of me
and I get up there to the top
and dude, I swear, this
is when I cried again.
I was like, Lando, this
is the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen.
There's was snow on this trail and you
have view of the red
rocks and it was as quiet
as Christmas Eve before Santa and
I called Christy, I was like,
you bail on this but
you have to get dressed
and you have to hike up here and see this
and she came up there and
she was like tearing up,
it was so beautiful up there and so quiet
and she was like, this is like Narnia
and I thought about you and
your obsession with Narnia.
Dude, I went to Narnia.
- Did you find a lamp post?
- I went to winter Narnia, no lamp post.
- It wasn't Narnia.
- Took lots of photos.
- Did you find any goat tracks?
- No.
Okay, it wasn't actually Narnia, I get it.
- But just one set, just a set of two
'cause he was half goat.
- I mean, the entire thing, I was just,
I was just struck with, for my family,
I try to adopt this mentality but then I'm
trying to apply it to life
and a New Year's resolution
type way is just trying to,
maybe we've talked about this,
but to set up, you can't
create moments like that
or all the moments that we had,
the tear-up moments, but
you can set the table
for something memorable to happen,
for the place to get filled
up with smoke, so to speak,
you know and it's just,
there's an art to saying, okay,
I can't force this but I can set the table
for something amazing.
We can go here.
We can go to this place and do a walk and
maybe the snow will dump,
maybe something magical will happen.
- It might have been a
totally different trip
if it hadn't snowed.
- You know, I can't say it's
not related to the vortex.
- But the vortex isn't at your house.
- Why not?
- Maybe you have a vortex at your house?
- Maybe I do.
- Maybe vortexes make you cry.
- Maybe they do.
- I had a slightly different,
slightly different experience.
- No snow in Mexico.
Caba-licious.
- I enjoyed being with the
family that we had in town
but I have a certain capacity for just
people at my house and
regardless of how well
we're getting along and
the fun that we're having.
- I get it.
- We had a great time, as families,
we watched a lot of movies.
I saw Bird Box, suddenly
all the memes made sense.
Saw Aqua Man, I watched
my wife watch Jason Momoa.
- Oh.
- And that was interesting
but I got to take in
Amber Heard in sort of a similar way,
which I had license to do that.
- Oh.
- In her Aqua suit or whatever it was.
- I heard that.
- And then,
so we saw movies but by the end of it
I was kind of like, I am,
I kind of and I knew this and this is why
I planned this trip to
Cabo with just Jessie,
I was like, I'm gonna
need some time to myself
and just me and my wife
after having everybody in town.
So we went down to Cabo,
just for like four days
and had a very relaxing time.
I actually ended up working
but I don't call it work 'cause, you know,
like writing songs and
working on some other things
we can't talk about,
but stuff that you could do next to a pool
in sort of a relaxing fashion
and I got the, and did the photo shoot,
which, you know, I'm
very proud of (laughs).
- Well, you gotta fill the listeners in
'cause they don't know
what the photo shoot is,
I don't think you said that at the top.
- Well, no, yeah so,
when we got to this place,
they were orienting us
to what was, you know,
the options and the
place and they were like,
oh, there's a complimentary photo shoot.
I knew that by complimentary
photo shoot they meant,
somebody's gonna take
photos of you and then
charge you a lot of money for the photos
that they took, it's not
really complimentary.
- So the shoot is free but
the photos are expensive?
- But Jessie had gotten me
this watermelon bathing suit
and matching watermelon
shirt, almost as a joke,
not ever thinking I
would wear them together.
I've worn them both independently.
I think I wore the watermelon shirt
on the show at one point.
But I put the whole package together,
if there's any place
to do it, it's Cabo and
I was like, this is what I'm
wearing for the photo shoot,
what are you wearing?
So, Jessie and I took some photos together
but then I was like, obviously I gotta get
something by myself.
I mean, this is kind of a special outfit.
- Okay, now tell me why that was obvious?
- Just because, I mean.
(Rhett laughs)
You saw the photo.
I think I created a vortex in Cabo.
- Oh, gosh.
Give me a break.
- I don't know how the vortexes happen but
if there was not a vortex
around me while I had
that watermelon suit on on the beach,
then I don't believe in vortexes.
- Oh, gosh.
- And the interesting thing was is
you know me, of the two of us,
I'm the one that is a little more worried
about what people think.
- Uh-huh.
- And also, I'm always, I'm
very overly irrationally
sensitive to how big I am.
I'm just a very large person,
so I kind of feel like,
if I do anything, if I
get out there and dance,
whatever I do, you're gonna see me do it
because you can't miss me, right?
- [Link] Right.
- And so--
- And you're not even factoring in
being covered in watermelons.
- You're right and so,
I'm like, I gotta put this watermelon on,
I'm gonna walk all around this resort.
- You're getting cold feet on us.
- No, I knew I was gonna do it
but I couldn't just relax into it.
I wanted to just relax into my identity
as the guy who wears
the watermelon outfit.
I just wanted to be that guy
and as I'm getting that picture taken,
all the people who are eating breakfast
at the restaurant that overlooks the beach
are just looking at me like,
look at this douche, you
know what I'm saying?
This guy obviously thinks this is cool
and I wanna be able to be like,
I know that this is funny.
I don't know why and I told Jessie,
I was like, that's my
New Year's resolution,
is just to quit caring, quit caring about
what people think.
Create your own vortex.
Be your own vortex.
That's what my t-shirt says.
- But Photoshop the leg wound after,
I will add that.
- But you know what--
- Airbrush it.
- It's all part of the story though.
It's all part of the story and
you know,
and by the time this is out,
that picture will be on
my Instagram as well.
I mean, shout out to
@rhettmc on Instagram,
I haven't done that in
awhile but you know what,
there's a vortex happening
over there on Instagram
right now and you can be a part of it.
Maybe if you double click that picture,
you'll create your own vortex
right there with your thumb.
I don't know how the internet works
but if you wanna get into my vortex,
create your own vortex,
we'll have just a web of vortexes,
maybe the whole world will become a vortex
and it starts with going over to @rhettmc
and liking that photo.
Sorry.
(Rhett laughs)
So, that was kind of,
it's kind of selfish,
I realize that, especially contrasted with
how you wept (chuckles),
you wept in the presence
of your family.
(Link laughs)
For me, I think my holiday
really just comes down
to that single photo of
me in the watermelon.
- Yep.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
Oh, gosh.
- No, I had an incredible
time with my wife.
We needed the time even
though it was just a few days.
I got offered coke on the streets of Cabo
by at least seven people.
- Like Diet Coke?
- It was the Diet Coke and the Cherry Coke
and just Coke Classic, Coke Zero,
they had every kind of coke
that you could imagine.
- How was it?
- I didn't trust it (laughs).
You know, I just didn't trust it
and so I didn't say yes to that.
- Okay, for the record,
you said no.
- I said no, I am not interested in that.
But one of the more notable things,
I'll never forget and it's
one of those things that,
there's these things that happen to you
and then the become part
of your personal canon
whenever you interact with an object
and let me explain.
We have some of the these
things between the two of us.
I'm at the pool and
I order a quesadilla.
You know, it was pool side restaurant,
they'll bring you whatever you want,
great service, whatever.
- Love it.
- And they bring me a
quesadilla and the guy
comes and sets it down and it's, you know,
it's sort of the half moon,
it's the folded over tortilla
as a quesadilla is, it's pretty
recognizable food product.
- Okay.
Yeah.
- And an old man walks by,
comes up and he's like,
what do you call that (laughs)?
- Really?
- Yes, he's like, what do you call that?
And I was like, a quesadilla.
(Rhett and Link laugh)
And he was like, and instead of saying,
oh, I didn't know it was a quesadilla,
he was like, huh and then he goes over
and starts talking to his wife.
I'm like, they discovered money.
I introduced someone to a quesadilla.
- You'll never believe this thing.
- And so, then--
- And you'll never
believe how they spell it.
- So, now this is what I'm getting at,
this whole personal canon thing,
which is one of the
things I love about life.
So then when we, when Jessie
and I are at the airport
getting ready to
leave Cabo because we have
a certain credit card,
we get into this lounge area.
- Oh, I know what they had.
- And they had a quesadilla
and I bring it back,
I got it on my plate and I'm like,
what do you call this?
(Link laughs)
- You had a little laugh.
- Yeah, had a little laugh.
- Had a little shared--
- And so, now for the rest of my life,
anytime I'm with my wife
and we order a quesadilla,
one of us is gonna say,
what do you call that?
- That's couple canon.
- Yeah, couple canon, man,
it's a couple canon quesadilla.
- Yeah, that's it.
- Create your own vortex.
- That's the thing about,
you know, relationships.
Hey, you know, we're 18,
19 years in to marriage,
add a couple of years when dating,
it's like you gotta keep
adding to the couple canon.
- Yeah, you got to.
- You know and so and
quesadillas are so prevalent.
That's good, that's a good
reminder of that moment.
- Not where that man's from.
- Don't go, except where that guy's from.
- Now, not a sponsor,
one of the last things
that I'd like to do is
this was the present
my wife got for me, which is,
she thought I would like a 360 camera.
She was right.
- Oh.
- Jacob, Kiko, I warned Kiko about this.
- [Jacob] Okay (laughs).
- I'm taking a picture.
- Jacob wore his pants with his knees out.
(Rhett laughs)
He says, uh-oh, my knees are out.
- I hope this is gonna work,
I'm gonna take a 360 degree
photo of our studio right now
and then I'm going to,
where can you post 360 degree photos?
- Just take it.
- I'm gonna Tweet out wherever
you can get this to this.
- Do you have to rotate it?
- No, you take, one, two, three.
(camera blips)
- [Both] That was it.
- It's like Men In Black.
- [Jacob] I think you
can chop them up and put
them on Instagram.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Chop 'em up on Instagram.
- Well, you better believe,
if it can be on Instagram, it will be,
shout out to @rhettmc.
If not, I'm gonna Tweet it out.
- Alright, well,
man, so we've caught up.
(upbeat music)
Here we are, holiday's caught up.
We got 2019 is just
bustling out before us and
let's walk that red
carpet, shall we, together.
Every week we're gonna bring
you another Ear Biscuit,
let's go through 2019 together.
Bring your friends along.
Go to iTunes or wherever you're listening,
could be Spotify, I
don't know wherever else,
leave a review
and all that stuff helps
but bring in people
into this world of friendship
and honesty and laughs, tears.
- The friendship vortex.
- All of it.
- That might be the subtitle
for 2019 of this Ear Biscuits.
- Do it.
Thank you for hanging out with us.
I mean, shoot, Conan's got a podcast now.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean.
- I mean, just the
competition's getting stiff.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
- You probably shouldn't
have even mentioned his.
- Yeah.
- Take it back, we take it back,
he doesn't have a podcast,
don't go looking for it.
We'll talk with you next week.
- Only us.
Or at least us first, I don't know.
One of the other things I did,
I didn't get to, I'll just tell you,
this'll be quick but we
were eating dinner in Sedona
in the place and I was playing music,
I was playing like Lord
Huron and I was like,
I was just thinking a
lot about the kids when
they get older and I
was thinking, you know,
20 years from now, I'm 60,
I would love to know
that I could rent a place
and have the family come
back and I was like,
I was seeing this.
I was like, Lily,
20 years from now, you're
gon' be 35 years old,
you might have a partner and have kids
and Lincoln, who knows
what you'll be doing,
Lando, I don't know, he'll be 28.
You guys could all have lives,
you'll have lives of your own
and what if I bring you back
and we're all hanging out
like after Christmas and some vortex and
what if you had this
idea that you were gonna
go over to whatever,
the way music was played
and you go over and you
would play something,
like would you even know,
as like a sweet moment,
would you even know
the music that your dad
always played in the house
when you were growing up?
Would you even know what that is,
like when I was a kid,
I knew my mom played Al
Greene and Lionel Ritchie,
so important to me now
and Michael Jackson.
I know that she, that's
the stuff that was played,
would you know that?
Do you know who this is
that's playing right now
and they were like, uh, Fleet Foxes?
(Rhett laughs)
That's wrong but that's good and that
would have worked, it's Lord Huron.
So, 20 years from now,
when we're all together,
I don't want you to say a word,
I want you to go over,
I was talking to Lily.
She's the most reliable one, I felt like,
with this kind of promise.
I want you to, in whatever
way music is played,
when we're all together 20 years from now,
you got lives of your own
but we're all back together,
I want you to play some
Lord Huron and then
I'm gonna start hearing
it and I'm gonna remember
this moment and I want you to promise
that you're gonna remember this
and it's gonna be called
the Lord Huron Promise.
We'll shorten it to just
the Huron Promise because
the Lord Promise sounds like something's
probably already taken
and she was like, okay,
Dad, you're being weird.
- (laughs) Oh, really?
- But I made her promise,
so 20 years from now, in 2038,
I'm gonna be with my
family and all of a sudden
this song's gonna play
and my daughter will
have remembered the promise.
(upbeat music)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(upbeat music)